In this video, we’re gonna be going over
a couple of reasons why you absolutely should
NOT buy the new Galaxy Note 10 that Samsung
just revealed at their unpacked event.
Now there’s also the Note 10+, which looks
to be a much better phone, but as we’ll
talk about in a minute, you should probably
think twice about buying that model as well!
We just finished the Note 10 event, and we
noticed that Samsung talked about a lot of
features that are already available on their
S10 line of phones.
For example, the S10 already has the same
exact Dynamic AMOLED Display, except that
it’s actually 1440p instead of only 1080p
on the Note 10, which is a shocker!
The S10 already has the ultrasonic fingerprint
sensor that they showed off.
It also seems to have the same exact cameras
as the Note 10.
Samsung didn’t mention any camera differences
at all, except for the Live Focus video feature,
which seems to be only coming on the Note
10+, since it has the 3D Depth sensor.
The Note 10 actually still has the same exact
processor as the S10.
Their spec sheets shows that the Note 10 has
the SM8150 7nm processor, but that’s actually
the codename for the Snapdragon 855 that’s
already in the S10.
So there’s no difference there.
They touted the vapor chamber on the new Note
10, but the S10 already has that.
They mentioned support for Fast Wireless charging
2.0, and yep, the S10 has that as well.
And basically everything else they showed
off was either already available on the S10,
or a software feature, like Samsung Dex, which
is yet again, available on the S10.
They did mention continuity between the Note
10 and Windows computers, which I think is
really cool, but that’s also coming to the
S10 as well.
I’d say the biggest difference is the S-Pen,
which has gotten some pretty impressive updates,
but to be honest, we still think it’s a
gimmick, I’ll let Max explain why.
Hey guys, I’ve owned 3 different Note’s
2 of which I used as my main device long term
and I think my experience with them match
up with a lot of people I know as well as
other reviewers.
Whenever I got a new Note I played around
with the S-Pen for a few days to a week, tried
out the new features, and generally thought
it was really cool, but after that I ended
up rarely using it and long term didn’t
use it all.
If you’ve owned a note let me know your
experience with it the s-pen and how often
you use it down in the comment section below.
For the most part, I think people bought Note
devices because they wanted a bigger screen,
but recently Samsung has made their S series
of phones have big screens as well, with the
S10+ having an even bigger screen then the
Note 10, so for most people thats no longer
a selling point.
Alright, back to you Vadim.
So when you take a look at everything you
get with the new Note 10 compared to the S10,
it doesn’t really seem worth it.
The S10 has a higher resolution display, it
actually comes with a headphone jack, which
is scrapped on the Note 10, and the S10 comes
with a MicroSD card slot, which, according
to MKBHD, is gone on the Note 10.
So all in all, you really don’t get much
of anything new or very impressive on the
Note 10.
And seeing as the S10 has been around for
a couple of months already, you can now find
it for as low as $600 refurbished on Amazon
with a warranty in the U.S.
Or, if you’re fine with buying used, you
can find one on craigslist for even less than
that, and those prices should go down even
more with the release of the Note phones.
So for those reasons, we recommend that you
DO NOT buy a Galaxy Note 10, and go buy a
Galaxy S10 for much less cash and enjoy the
better display, headphone jack and microSD
card slot.
Now let’s talk about the Note 10+, which
is the star of the show.
You get a larger 6.8” screen with 1440P
resolution, a larger battery, a microSD card
slot, the 3D depth camera for scanning objects
and using Live Focus Video mode, you get up
to 512GB of storage with a microSD card slot,
and finally, you get 45W Super Fast Charging
if you buy the brick separately.
And even with all of that, the Note 10+ still
feels a bit mediocre.
The S10+ has the same great display, albeit
not as large, you can actually get 1TB of
storage on the S10+ with the ceramic model,
which also comes with 12GB of RAM, just like
the Note 10+.
The processors are yet again, exactly the
same, and the cameras are basically the same,
except for lacking the 3D Depth camera.
And if you really want that, you can get the
S10 5G, which comes with the 3D Depth camera,
5G networking and an even larger battery than
the Note 10+.
What I’m trying to say is that there really
isn’t that much new and special about even
the Note 10+ as well.
Of course, it’s gonna be a great phone,
and a lot of people are gonna buy it, but
it starts at $1100, and it’s not much better
than the S10+, which you can find for much
cheaper online or find used for even less.
Now here’s something else to think about.
Apple’s iPhone event is next month, and
they’re coming out with new iPhones which
will pack their upcoming A13 processor, and
seeing as the current A12 processors are already
on-part with the Snapdragon 855 in the Note
10+, we should be seeing a massive boost in
performance on the iPhone 11.
And we’re actually planning on buying the
Note 10+, just so we could compare it to the
iPhone XS Max and the upcoming iPhone 11,
so if you’re not already subscribed, you
should do so now!
So basically, you’ve got a couple of options.
You can buy the Note 10 or Note 10+, which
really aren’t that impressive.
Or you can save some cash and go with one
of the Galaxy S10-line phones, or you can
wait a month for Apple’s iPhone 11.
Let us know your thoughts down below, and
make sure to tap like if you enjoyed the video.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!